vamos a descubrir cómo programar más
figuras vamos a empezar con las que ya
conocemos elipses tengo este programa
que dibuja la cara de mi buen amigo
winston
usa cuatro funciones de elipse para
dibujar esta cara
si quisiera cambiar algo de esta cara
aunque es perfecta así como ésta tendría
que encontrar la elipse correcta y luego
el parámetro correcto en la elipse
así que digamos que su boca queremos que
esté realmente emocionado esta es la
última elipse y la anchura es el tercer
número así que puedo incrementarlo y
aquí va a winston está bien eso fue
divertido pero qué podemos hacer además
de lidge es bueno podemos hacer
rectángulos usando la función rect otro
comando que nuestro programa sabe cómo
obedecer darán un rectángulo así como el
lips el comando rect requiere cuatro
parámetros y en realidad son muy
similares a los cuatro parámetros que la
función de lips necesita vamos a usar
este rectángulo para dibujar un cuello
de tortuga para winston vamos a llevar
el cuello de tortuga debajo del cuello
de winston
entonces lo llevamos abajo abajo abajo
aquí vamos
luego vamos a hacerlo más ancho porque
winston tiene un cuello ancho
ahora creo que deberíamos moverlo un
poco más finalmente lo vamos a hacer más
alto hasta que se pase de la parte baja
de la pantalla
hermoso
ahora puedes ver que la función rect
necesita cuatro parámetros los primeros
dos controlan la posición el x y el y
los otros dos controlan el tamaño la
anchura y la altura parece exactamente
lo mismo que con la función elipse
cierto casi pero no del todo te mostraré
a qué me refiero dibujando una nueva
elipse con los mismos números que este
rectángulo
arrastramos eso luego este es 128 luego
este debería ser
vamos a llevarlo hasta 346
luego este es 139
ahora estos dos están en la posición 128
y 346 eso significa 128 píxeles desde el
lado izquierdo y 346 píxeles abajo desde
la parte superior por cierto un píxel es
el tamaño de un punto en la pantalla de
tu computadora recuerda que nuestra
pantalla de dibujo es de 400 píxeles de
ancho x 400 píxeles de alto así que
nuestros números deben estar entre 0 y
400 nuestra elipse también está en la
posición 128 y 346 pero en realidad no
están en el mismo lugar
la elipse empieza antes que el
rectángulo y termina a la mitad de él
como puede ser eso si especificamos la
misma posición para los dos esto es
porque los rectángulos y las élites
interpretan los parámetros de posición
de manera diferente un rectángulo usa
los parámetros de posición para definir
la esquina superior izquierda y una
elipse usa los parámetros de posición
para definir el punto central aquí
puedes ver que en realidad el punto
central de la leche es exactamente la
esquina superior del rectángulo
y ese punto justo aquí está a 128
píxeles desde la izquierda y 346 píxeles
hacia abajo si queremos la elipse justo
arriba del rectángulo necesitamos
agregar más píxeles a su posición para
traerla justo aquí y luego bajarla hasta
aquí y ahora está en el mismo lugar
podrías estresarte por todos esos
números y las sumas y las restas que
estoy haciendo pero no te preocupes no
tienes que poner los números correctos
en tu primer intento
prueba con algunos números para que veas
cómo cambian las figuras y continúa
probando números hasta que te guste lo
que ves si tienes papel cuadriculado
primero puedes tratar de dibujar sus
figuras con lápiz y papel a mí eso me
ayuda mucho ahora que he mostrado esto
voy a borrar esta elipse porque él no
necesita una elipse en su cuello de
tortuga déjame mostrarte otra figura una
línea que usaré para dibujar una unicaja
sobre los ojos de winston justo aquí
arrastramos line y vemos una vez más que
hay cuatro parámetros que podemos
cambiar
vamos a empezar cambiando la posición o
lo que pensamos que es la posición
queremos que quede sobre los ojos así
que incrementamos x
y luego la bajamos un poco
ok ahora empieza sobre el ojo pero
termina hasta acá
por qué
bueno estos dos parámetros 50/50 no son
anchura y altura porque las líneas no
tienen ancho y alto
en lugar de eso las líneas tienen un
punto de inicio y un punto final estos
dos parámetros deben ser el punto final
de la línea
voy a continuar y voy a mover el punto
final para que quede sobre este ojo
y voy a cambiar para que sea como la del
otro lado
porque eso formará una línea horizontal
lindo winston se ve bien
ahora dejen de mostrarles una cosa más
sobre el dibujo de formas ves cómo se
ordenan nuestras llamadas a funciones en
el área de edición tenemos el leaf el
lips el lips y luego red y luego line
ese orden es realmente muy importante
porque es el orden en que nuestro
programa va a correr el código de arriba
a abajo la primera figura dibujada es la
elipse y tres hélices más luego el
rectángulo y luego la línea porque eso
es importante observa qué pasa se
arrastró line para que el comando quede
arriba de la primera elipse
ajá casi desaparece solo se asoma un
poco por aquí esto es porque el programa
primero dibuja una línea y luego dibuja
todo lo demás sobre ella hasta que casi
no podemos ver la línea recuerda esto
cuando hagas tus dibujos porque
probablemente quiera dibujar figuras en
un orden particular en la parte superior
de otra si no encuentras una figura que
ha dibujado tal vez esté oculta detrás
de otra figura y como probablemente no
tienes visión de rayos x para verla solo
arrastra tu código por todas partes para
ver qué pasa abarcamos mucho en esta
elección pero úsalo y sigue explorando y
pronto lo vas a dominar